when you're trying to build uh trusting
teams it's you you recognize that you
cannot enforce certainty uh on people
you can offer goals people like goals um
but what's important is how we get there
not not just that we got there think of
it like think of it like um trying to
lose weight
right
there's nothing wrong with setting
arbitrary goals with arbitrary dates
which is by the way how we build our
businesses we want to hit x amount of
dollars in revenue by probably the end
of the year because that's when we pay
taxes it's a completely arbitrary number
somebody might say we could do better
than that you're like you're right and
then we change the number right complete
works of fiction that so we're striving
to hit a work of fiction right
um
and it's the same when we want to lose
weight i want to lose x amount of pounds
by x date
arbitrary right and we're doing all the
things to do that we're you know we're
exercising eating well all the things we
love standing on the scale we love a
metric there's nothing wrong with that
human beings need that
we can't run in a marathon without mile
markers it's actually unnerving we need
to know how fast and how far so the
metrics are good
and let's say you hit your goal right
you hit your performance goal just as as
you uh had articulated amazing you feel
incredible you feel like you've
succeeded here's the problem you have to
keep exercising for the rest of your
life
right in other words you don't stop
doing the things that you were doing so
the game hasn't ended it was simply a
waypoint but what i think is more
interesting is what happens if you miss
your goal what happens if you don't lose
the amount of weight that you wanted on
that date and the and the answer is
nothing
nothing happens because you're probably
way healthier than you are now than you
were you're probably on the easily you
can see the trend data you can see
you're well on your way to hitting your
goal you just pick the wrong date you're
easily going to hit it in another month
if you just stick to your regime
business is the same which is sometimes
we miss our goals but the question is
how what's the trend data you know is
the team working well together is morale
high
is some of it out of our control you
know market conditions and things like
that things we didn't we didn't know
about and so if we happen to miss the
number the problem is is how are we
rewarding our people and so many of us
only reward our people based on if they
hit the number but what if they're
begging borrowing and stealing what if
they simply rush at the end of the
quarter to
to drop their prices or have some sort
of promotion or or or have some some
trickery they'll hit the number
and then we bonus them which tells
everybody else i don't care how you hit
your numbers as long as you hit them
well guess what kind of behavior that's
going to reinforce inside our
organization whereas if you look at the
data the trend data and you reward
somebody who's well on the path what
we're telling you is as long as you're
doing a good job you'll do well in this
organization
leaders understand
that they are not responsible for the
results they are responsible for the
people who are responsible for the
results and that skill set is very very
different than just trying to get people
to do the thing that you know how to do
better than them because you've been
doing it your whole life